well if we can clean up the
communication if we can get rid of the
politicians who lie like Whitmer and the
bureaucrats who who want power over you
that they don't deserve like fauci what
can we get back to well we could get
back to a state that is slim and trim
and respectful of our rights because it
didn't give us our rights it is there to
defend those rights this is a beautiful
throwback video we got for you a former
prime minister of Britain Margaret
Thatcher on why the state
is not necessarily your friend when it
comes to Freedom
the essence of socialism is that you
surrender quite a bit of power over your
own life to the state where we all do
that to some extent but of course it
went much further
you pay very high taxes and they wish to
um take even higher taxes because they
think that politicians can spend money
better than the people can spend it the
more you take away the less there is for
Private Industry and that's where the
creation of wealth comes so you have to
establish very clear limits on the role
of government and really you'll know
politicians I think should sometimes
just be a little bit more modest about
their abilities than they are we can't
run everything and we shouldn't
is the bachelor though you're going for
Attitudes you're trying to change the
way people think about their role in
life it's almost sometimes as though you
think by your own resolve you can
somehow inspire people to be different
you're still inside if I could suggest a
little of that very bright green
Grocer's daughter who made herself a
chemist made herself a tax lawyer made
herself prime minister anybody can
I don't really quite recognize what
you're saying I believe certain things
very strongly
I believe that we were going towards a
way of life in which people were
constantly looking to the state to solve
their problems and to do things for them
you know when the state does everything
for you it'll soon take everything from
you
you will then have no basis for personal
freedom
political freedom
nor economic freedom I saw it going much
too far and I think it would have gone
even further had I not won that 1979
election too far ever to pull it back
do I have to even add much to that is
that not the heart of everything that I
talk about here
imagine if the state was just slim and
trim and it couldn't give everything to
you and it couldn't take everything away
it had no power to lock you in your
house or force you to be ejected with
something sure it made sure there were
police they made sure we had a border
a couple other little things
but then it stayed out of your way and
you had more money in your pocket to do
with your resources what you see fit
and you could speak freely and all of
that stuff that's how this is all set up
to be and we have been getting very
close to that Cliff where we would give
it all away and this is a cyclical thing
in time that's what she's talking about
there because uh she had an election
where she felt hey we're getting close
to socialism we're getting close to
giving it away that's where we're at
we're close we're close and if the
election does not go the way that I
think it will go the signal will have
been sent to all of the people that want
more control over your lives Gavin
Newsom will get the signal and he'll go
I'll keep going Gretchen Whitmer will
get the signal she'll go I'll keep going
then Trudeau will look at the election
and go ah see look at those Americans
I'm going to keep going and they will
keep going and going and going Kathy
hochel will keep going